the jurogan experience joe biden owns
come on man now
that is true it really does come on man
crystal was just showing me a video that
he flipped out
at some reporter today did you see this
he's at this summit with putin
and biden lost his [ __ ] he was asked a
question that he didn't like he turned
around and started yelling
no yeah no he was very cranky cranky old
man status
in this dude i think he's from fox news
jamie if you want to show
joe that he's legitimately falling apart
and it's really sad
you know what's really weird though is
the media's
first of all the left-wing media
completely ignoring how odd it is the
way he behaves like
the one nine-year-old girl that was
sitting there with her legs crossed like
look at her over there look at her
like a 19 year old girl their legs
crossed like what the [ __ ] are you
saying like what is that
so there's the whole i'm sorry but then
they'll like pretend things are
happening that aren't like glenn
greenwald called it out today on twitter
i was reading his twitter feed some guy
was
talking about how putin and biden
shook hands and then how putin looked
away
and then biden's look at him in the eyes
as if he's trying to say
that in any way putin
is scared of joe biden that joe biden
is like dominating putin like what if
bizarre
like and glenn described it perfectly
like go to glen
greenwald's twitter because it's it's so
strange because they do this thing
where these world leaders they shake
hands they look at the camera and they
shake hands and look at the press
and so in that moment biden had
forgotten to look at the at the press
and he's making it seem like biden's
staring him down
he's showing him what a real man's like
it's like a bizarre
fantasy like almost like a pro wrestling
thing
like you know that you can't possibly
believe what you're saying is true
that putin who's a [ __ ] straight-up
killer literally
in a judo black belt who's the [ __ ]
head of the soviet union well
whatever union russia forever and
probably
until he dies killed a gang of people
killed a bunch of people don't like him
killed a bunch of people talk [ __ ] about
them made journalists disappear
allegedly allegedly all those things i
said allegedly
like oh they're gonna shake one okay
they look at each other shaking the eye
and then putin looks away to the press
and by the way
they're making something imagine look at
this but look at this
look you scroll up please yeah please
scroll no don't
where you where you had it so i could
see it just don't worry
uh biden looked poot in the eye putin
immediately looked away
what but go to go to green walls because
the way he covered it is hilarious
the way greenwald made fun of him what
act well
if you go click show this thread
so scroll down there scroll right there
nope back right there the obsession over
who squeezed whose hands hardest
who led i guess he meant let go who let
go
first of the grip whose body language
shows masculine authority and whose
shows submission is [ __ ] demented a
bunch of liberal professionals not
allowed to speak this way except here
so true that's exactly what it is he
said joe biden can barely complete a
sentence
half the time he drifts off in the
middle of his words he's constantly
bowing his head and muttering about
how he'll get in trouble if he continues
nobody is [ __ ] afraid of him
stop feeding liberal [ __ ] this warped
palbum
pablum that's a weird word so um
problem you ever use that word jamie
pavlin's a good word
so it's interesting because this is why
people hate the media right you
everybody feels like they're arguing
more from a narrative than they are just
sort of objectively describing what's
happening
and with biden it's particularly weird
because early on in the democratic
primary
when the media was convinced it's not
going to be biden it's going to be
bootage or it's going to be kamala
harris or it's going to be you know
whoever fill in the blank with
whoever imploded and was terrible they
actually
were open and honest about the fact for
example that joe biden's sort of
sundowning and he's not all there and he
can't really complete full sentences and
so they actually were the ones who
brought it up in debates with him for
example julian castro very famously was
like
do you even know what you just said like
five seconds ago this was a big moment
in the debate
and so the media would openly talk about
i don't know if joe's all there anymore
but the second that he got the
nomination they stopped
nobody's allowed to say it and if you
say it you're you're trying you're a
right winger exactly
even though you know i'm i was the
biggest bernie supporter out there and i
was like
here's a compilation of joe biden
clearly having some mental issues
yeah and so it was just incredibly
dishonest um
i've been to your point on putin and
russia
the narrative that they're using for
biden is he's tough he's standing up to
him
it was the exact opposite for trump
where they were saying oh he's a he's
vladimir putin's puppet
yeah you know and they're actually
incorrect for both of those things so in
terms of
uh what trump was doing trump bombed
syria who's
russia's top ally trump rejected this
pipeline called the nordstrom pipeline
which would have greatly helped russia
trump armed ukrainian rebels
on the ground who are fighting russia
trump did a nato buildup
on russia's border now i don't agree
with those policies
but those policies are incredibly
hawkish and raise tensions with russia
now in the case of biden biden actually
just approved
the nordstream 2 pipeline which is a
pipeline that's going to greatly help
russia because it makes it so that
russian oil and gas is going to be used
in germany now and so that's a very
that's a very peaceful move that's not
hawkish that's not raising tensions
so he's basically giving putin something
that putin wants which again i actually
agree with that i see no problem with
the pipeline but they're framing it as
if like
joe biden he's so weak and and he's you
know
vladimir putin or excuse me joe biden is
so strong and he's dominating vladimir
putin
yeah i i don't understand why they think
that they can do that and that people
won't be
more hesitant to believe the news dude
you would be surprised at
unfortunately some of this stuff lands
there is a backlash to it but some of
this stuff lands
i saw a great pew poll the other day
when it came to donald trump
it was like over 70 percent of the time
they talked about him
they would talk about his like character
and leadership qualities or lack thereof
yeah and so when that's how you're
talking about the person you said oh the
[ __ ] you want
because what does that even mean let me
talk about this person's character it's
subjective somebody could say i think
he's got great character somebody could
say i think he's got terrible character
so it was always out of the realm of
policy right and then that same poll it
was like 60 or 65 percent of the time
when they talked about biden
they talked about policy um so it's it
there was this
huge dichotomy in how they they
discussed the presidents and obviously
the ones
who they like they'd go a little softer
on and when it came to trump and they
despised him
they would talk about and the crazy
thing the thing that drives me crazy joe
is that there are a lot of ways to go
after trump that are actually very
intelligent that i would agree with
when you stick to policy i disagree with
him on almost everything when it comes
to policy but they didn't do that
right it was all about he you know yeah
character assassination all day long
which is
gross do you think that biden is making
actual decisions
um that's a good question um
i don't think i would ever say that
about any other president other than
trump some some of the trump stuff i was
like i wonder like how much he like
pawns off on the generals well w bush
was also an idiot too
you know but we all knew that dick
cheney was he was pulling the puppet
strings yeah so in the case of of
biden i think it's it's 50 50. i think
some of the stuff he probably makes in
some of the stuff he doesn't
i mean he def he clearly is having
struggles mentally and he's getting very
old and i think everybody around him
knows that
but a lot of the big decisions i'm sure
they have to land on his desk um
what did they do for him during the
debates with trump when he was sharp
about one debate
they had to i and i said this too with
the bernie debate as well i really
and this is all speculation i just want
everybody to know i have no facts on
this i'm talking out of my ass
but yeah i think he was on some sort of
upper that allowed him to be sharp
i feel like it had to be more than that
so you think it's something like uh
anti i don't know psychotic or but he
was
he was in the groove like he acted like
a normal person well when he was younger
he actually
again i don't agree with him politically
i think he's a terrible corporatist but
he was
sharp in terms of debating there was
that debate with paul ryan in 2012.
you remember that he made paul ryan look
like a little baby oh really oh yeah the
2012 vp debate
it was amazing you're such a politics
fan you talk about debates
like some people talk about playoff
games and guess what
i watch them like that too i got my
popcorn i got twitter up i'm live
tweeting them i get all excited and into
it
catch new episodes of the joe rogan
experience for free only on spotify
watch back catalog jre videos on spotify
including clips easily seamlessly switch
between
video and audio experience on spotify
you can listen to the jre in the
background while using other apps and
can download episodes to save on data
cost
all for free spotify is absolutely
free you don't have to have a premium
account to watch new jre
episodes you just need to search for the
jre on your spotify app
go to spotify now to get this full
episode
of the joe rogan experience